Let's boil the
3,000 year history
of work down to three minutes.
First, there were
hunters and gatherers.
Everyone contributed,
and their business
was basically to survive.
Eventually they began to
tame plants and animals,
opening up new kinds of work.
And, if you were
lucky, pleasure.
In early civilizations,
powerful ruling classes
emerged for the first time.
They could outsource work
to slaves and servants
because that mundane,
hard work was considered
beneath their dignity,
even though it
made their lifestyles possible.
In the Middle Ages, new
religious philosophies
changed that.
Working hard became synonymous
with doing good, pleasing God,
and repenting for one's sins.
Then came the rise
of the family farm.
Working the land took
on a sense of community.
All family members
literally pitched in,
depended on each other, and the
farmer's work was never done.
But as civilization ticked
on, more and more people
moved to cities.
In those cities, artisans
specialized more and more,
and along came the
craft stage of work,
like shoemakers and
carpenters, all very skilled
and specialized.
Then the Industrial Revolution
came along and brought with it
mass production.
Humans adapted.
New kinds of factories
created new kinds
of workers eager to earn a
living however they could
in a rapidly changing world.
Some workers banded together.
They took historic stands
for humane work conditions
and demanded all kinds of
fundamental rights including
the 40 hour work week.
The development of computers,
the World Wide Web,
and widespread
education ushered us
into the
knowledge-based economy.
As fewer people
and fewer hours are
needed to do the
work of yesterday,
people are adapting again.
Today some do work that didn't
even exist five years ago.
So here we are.
Is this the end of
work's evolution?
No.
How you live and work
will invent the future.
You'll work to eat.
You'll eat by outsourcing food
production to other workers.
You'll tap into a deep human
drive to work on something
and to make a genuine
difference doing it.
You'll rely on your networks
and connections to help you out,
and you will help
others in turn.
You'll specialize
in something no one
has thought of before
using technology
no one's seen before.
You'll wonder how to better tip
the balance of work and life
to the needs of a new world.
So keep on working,
creating, and inventing
the future of work.